[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau d'affaires conclut la rue
caroline c'est que quand on porte des
talons de 12 cm et d'un raul peut pas
s'attaquer avec actuellement une année
pépé le putois devait apparaître dans le
film space jam 2 qui va bientôt sortir
mais sa scène a été coupée au dernier
moment car le putois est au coeur d'une
polémique aux etats-unis selon un
éditorial du new york times ce pépé le
putois participe à la culture du viol
les blogs conservateurs m'en veulent
parce que j'ai dit que pépé le putois
participe est à la culture du viol dans
cette vidéo il attrape et embrasse une
fille qu'il ne connaît pas de manière
répétée sans son consentement et contre
sa volonté
avec son obsession pour la chatte
pénélope ils seraient un dragueur lourd
souvent un harceleur parfois un
agresseur sexuel
c'est pourquoi il sera bannie des
futures productions
[Musique]
c'est une règle que l'on connaît si bien
qu'on ne la remarque même plus aux
cartes
leroy l'emportent sur la reine
maintenant une météo incroyable
attention à vos souhaits mais oui très
bien alors cette jeune néerlandaise
indie mailing propose une autre solution
voilà mon nouveau jeu de cartes avec des
figures neutre sans visage lors remplace
le roi l'argent la reine et le bronze
le valais donne suite à nouveau gt eric
julien benedetto non c'est la mi temps
ici
une seule règle détruire
et encore détruire pour 25 euros mission
démolition avec tous ces objets douteux
recherché évacuer la pression liée aux
restrictions du quotidien dès qu'on a
mis le premier coup on peut se lâcher
c'est bon il ya plus de dix minutes on
s'amuse on se détend c'est chouette on
se laisse prendre au jeu des personnes
totalement vaccinés ont le droit de
revoir sans masquer leurs proches
notamment leurs petits enfants
vous allez voir l'émotion de cette mamie
qui vit dans l'état de new york et qui a
reçu vous l'avez vu une ordonnance de
son médecin pour faire un câlin à sa
petite fille elle en a pleuré
le gérant mise sur la crise sanitaire
pour séduire les clients
on a tous eu envie à un moment à la
maison de prendre un truc est de capter
par terre
mais après on est à la maison donc on
est là non on repose le virus at il été
transmis par un animal
la deuxième beaucoup plus délicate et
celle de l'accident de laboratoire et si
des scientifiques chinois avaient laissé
s'échapper dans la nature un coronavirus
ultra contagieux
le centre de virologie de wuhan est au
coeur de tous les soupçons
regardez cette image c'était le 14
décembre dernier à new york aux états
unis première vaccination contrôle
qu'ovide et bien la petite fiole
utiliser ce jour là vient de rejoindre
le musée national d'histoire américaine
de washington
elle intègre la collection d'objets liés
à la pandémie en 2015 avec une équipe de
chercheurs américains
elle a réussi à créer un virus mutant un
coronavirus de souris inoffensif à la
base a été mélangée aux strass mortel
pour l'homme
à partir de ces expérimentations les
laborantins ont créé 8 virus synthétique
de type strass capable d'infecter
l'homme en deux chercheurs en 2017 ont
étudié un panel de personnes qui
faisaient des selphy donc en inde et
parce que c'est le en fait c'est en inde
qui a le record du nombre de décès en
lien avec des sels fille et au qu'il en
ressort que le est une maladie mentale
oui peut-être chronique ou aiguë en
fonction du nombre de photos comprend de
soi ou de nombre de photos compost sur
les réseaux sociaux on a été extrêmement
surpris de voir que le virus avait l'air
d'être parfaitement façonné pour l'homme
l'homme venait largement devant toutes
les autres espèces étudiées
ce n'était pas du tout ce à quoi on
s'attendait
on a vraiment été choqué ce virologue
n'a jamais vu un tel coronavirus il
semble façonné pour contaminer l'homme
aurait-il été fabriqué en laboratoire
en tant que citoyen chez moi oui je pas
recevoir de représentant du rnd un
copain journée ce qui me dit j'espère
qu'ils ne vont pas te saouler avec ça
j'assume
il a vite jean castex il a vite françois
hollande mais il a dit qu'il n'avait
trait pas marine le pen sa marine le pen
des ratios ne faut pas l'inviter samuel
etienne il a raison il a raison faut
éviter ça s'appelle comment son truc
which twitch voilà tweet il travaille
sur tweets il y travaille sud service
lui on a vite pas marine le pen qui
représente 25 ans on avait arrêté enfin
c'est le diable détends toi j'ai juste
laïque et une de tes photos de ton chien
là ça devait être sur l'actualité de mon
réseau social et c'est tout mais elle à
0 répartis en fait je la mange direct
moi je me sens pas de recevoir des gens
du grâce au mouvement national chinois
voilà donc bon classieux ne sais pas je
sais je serai peut-être critiqué sur ça
mais voilà un moment il faut à la maison
je suis moi je suis je suis citoyen donc
voilà tant pis si tout le monde toute la
presse va dire mais il émerveillé
merveilleux ça me d'étiage est tellement
gentil il est tellement bienveillant il
est tellement formidable c'est juste
donne 20% des français à qui on est au
23 vous êtes des voix là on veut pas on
vous parle pas vous vous on vous parle
pas en fait c'est le mépris le mépris
institutionnels et c'est payé ma le
faire les publics vous n'avez ce soir
est dorénavant que mon pur mépris
hollande arrive sur l'estrade et dit
bonjour à darmanin et là on sent bonjour
aux gros bonjour le groupe réaction de
nicolas sarkozy on va revoir sa tête la
tête que fait nicolas sarkozy
mais qu'elle prive mensonges assurant
chez groupe datant des bâtiments c'est
moi qui parle petit médecin de santé
publique
vous venez petit mot à la terrible ouais
ouais ouais ouais ya quand même quelque
chose on s'en bat l'oeil que la mosson
balech de la batterie et son jazz il
on se complète sur place et c'est un
ouais c'est dégueulasse et pas d'autres
mots y'a pas d'autres mois ci